entendemos que la pintura es una forma
de expresarnos una manera que tenemos de
exteriorizar nuestros sentimientos
nuestra idea lo que sentimos a través de
cómo vivimos nuestro contexto y con con
nuestro entorno pero la pintura no
solamente ha servido para poder
exteriorizar nos y expresar todo eso que
sentimos sino que también nos ha servido
a lo largo de la historia del arte para
también poder investigar e investigar a
través de la pintura
también lo han hecho muchos artistas a
lo largo de la historia esta
investigación ha sido como muy muy
interesante poderla vivir y experimentar
ya que hay algo que nos ha unido a todos
y que nos ha llevado a poder descubrir
también a través de la pintura lo
maravilloso que es la naturaleza que
todos los artistas se han inspirado en
ella y han tratado también de poder
descifrar muchas cosas de la naturaleza
a través del arte dentro de las técnicas
que se han descubierto o experimentado
para poder representar esta naturaleza
en su manera fidedigna
una de las que más me llama la atención
y las que yo ocupo para pintar mis obras
es la técnica de la verdura
la veladura es una técnica que es de
óleo muy diluido en donde se va pintando
una capa por sobre la otra y la técnica
de veladura sirve y representa de manera
muy fidedigna lo que son las sombras
el trabajo en particular
se llama el desarrollo de la luz y es la
mezcla de astronomía y pintura
en un inicio yo me inspiré en la
imágenes del telescopio hubble que está
orbitando a 593 kilómetros por sobre el
nivel del mar y desde hace 27 años de
hecho yo y el telescopio hubble tenemos
la misma edad yo nací un mes antes que
el telescopio el que me ha inspirado y
el que fue el que me inspiró en un
inicio porque si vieran todas las
imágenes que yo represento del espacio
son las que tomó el telescopio también
después fue investigando y encontré
otros observatorios que me entregaron
otras imágenes o de repente astro
fotógrafos que tenían imágenes muy
bonitas que también me interesaban poder
retratar
o la misma que yo comencé a ver a través
de los telescopios como les contaba mi
investigación pictórica se llama el
desarrollo y la luz y aquí vamos a ver
un proceso de la primera obra que yo
pinté y lo que como pueden ver el
proceso de la dura
estas capas translúcidas muy
transparentes de óleo se van pintando
acaba por capa y representa muy bien lo
que es la sombra y la profundidad al
poder ir avanzando en el proceso de
pintura
yo voy pintando un color sobre el otro
en donde está el negro el espacio donde
como se alberga este objeto astronómico
que en este caso es una nebulosa en
ningún momento yo pinto con negro siendo
que el resultado como ustedes lo pueden
ver afuera es completamente oscuro pero
no es pintura negra sino que es la
superposición de color aquí se ve que en
ningún caso en la parte del espacio no
es la mariposa se ve el negro
y aquí va el proceso cuando yo estaba
más o menos por aquí me contacté a
través de facebook por el núcleo de
astronomía de la universidad diego
portales porque yo tenía esa necesidad
de saber y una curiosidad inmensa de
poder saber qué era lo que yo estaba
retratando porque si bien en internet
podría buscar algo no encontraba la
información que yo necesitaba para poder
seguir pintando simplemente por
curiosidad y gracias al núcleo de
astronomía que yo me entregaron el
conocimiento yo pude llegar a entender
bien cómo se formaban estos objetos y
también a entender el ya cómo poder
mezclar el conocimiento con la técnica
porque si bien este es una imagen que me
inspiraba mucho como imagen estética
también como concepto era súper potente
yo no sabía que una nebulosa era la
muerte de un sol y al poder saber eso
tener ese conocimiento
pude ampliar un poco más mi
investigación y también las ganas de
seguir haciendo esto porque es un
concepto súper potente la muerte es un
tabú hasta el día de hoy para todos hay
mucha gente que le teme a eso y si bien
en mi obra no solamente yo represento la
muerte sino que también el ciclo de vida
porque en el espacio podemos ver cómo a
través de la muerte se genera también la
vida y así está funcionando la vida
estelar por eso es tiene ese nombre el
desarrollo de la luz esta investigación
les quiero comentar también una anécdota
que tuve una vez cuando yo estaba
pintando esto en un centro cultural
estaba en el patio pintando y se me
acerca una señora y me dijo qué es lo
que pintas o mucha gente me pregunta que
es y yo le dije es una nebulosa es la
muerte de un sol como el nuestro porque
es una nebulosa planetaria no es una
supernova no es una muerte un sol
gigante sino que es un sol mediano y me
quiero mirando y emocionada me dijo me
encanta y de verdad es muy hermoso lo
que haces porque si todos supiéramos que
la muerte es tan bella quizás donde
tendríamos a morir
en ese momento para mí fue súper
emocionante también poder encontrar como
un propósito también de un concepto que
al cual poder hablar poder entablar esta
conversación entre más personas aquí
está como una foto de él
del cuadro ya ha finalizado y dónde
pueden ver que se ve completamente
oscuro donde no nunca hubo nada de negro
sino que es la superposición de colores
de hecho en el proceso yo iba a capa por
capa ya tiene una aproximadamente 60
capas de esta parte de oscura y ya no se
la capa número 30 yo pintaba un par de
estrellas después seguía pintando capas
entonces esas estrellas quedaban en la
profundidad y nuestro ojo tiene la
capacidad de poder traspasar estas capas
de transparencia de óleo y
tomar captar está profundidad
otra de las cosas interesantes que
aprendí y que descubrí al investigar más
era que el telescopio hubble entregaba
imágenes que nosotros no vemos y una de
las cosas como importantes también del
arte es poder representar todas esas
cosas que nos vemos entonces el
telescopio aquí puedes ver una imagen
que funciona con varias filtros que de
hecho nuestro campo de visibilidad es lo
que nosotros vemos es muy pequeño en
comparación con las imágenes que captura
el telescopio
aquí hay un detalle de otra obra que
también pueden ver en fuera y que se
llama la caída y aquí quiero destacar
una de las cosas importantes también
para mí
qué es poder exponer esto y no solamente
exponerlas y mostrar estas obras a los
demás sino que también acercar a la
gente a estas obras porque yo mezclo una
técnica académica muy antigua que nace
en el renacimiento de la veladura es una
técnica que ha pasado de maestro de
maestros y entonces esta técnica con una
tecnología que es el telescopio los
observatorios logró retratar y
representar imágenes que son casi
invisibles para nosotros yo no puedo
parar en el patio de mi casa y ver una
nebulosa como ésta en cambio si puedo
acercar un poco el universo a través de
la representación de estas imágenes a
través de un realismo abstracto o
realismo espacial porque tiene como la
unión de muchos conceptos
aquí está el cuadro completo imágenes
completamente abstractas y uno de los
motivos también que logró al poder
exponerla es aparte de entregar la
información en la visita guiada en las
exposiciones junto con erika en el
principio hacíamos estas visitas guiadas
y era muy entretenido porque ella
entregaba el conocimiento científico de
cómo se formaba y el ciclo estelar del
cual yo retrataba yo entrega el
conocimiento creativo de técnica y
después generamos una instancia en donde
podemos reinterpretar estas imágenes
cósmicas es decir que es lo que tú ves
aquí porque si bien esta imagen se llama
la nebulosa de la laguna
yo veo otra cosa veo otra historia en
esta imagen que le puse el nombre de la
caída y así cada uno puedes ver otra
cosa distinta porque es una imagen
completamente abstracta
una explosión solar es una mancha de luz
y de colores en el espacio entonces
podemos reinterpretar también esta
imagen es aquí una imagen de una visita
guiada y de lo entretenido que era
porque de repente la gente ve cosa muy
loca que yo no me imagino y que de
verdad es como como
bueno también dentro de mi
experimentación y de esta creación
artística he podido llegar a cosas super
entretenidas y que encuentro muy
importantes que es poder difundir la
ciencia a través del arte a través de la
acción porque no solamente es difundir y
enseñar de una manera teórica sino que
también entregar el conocimiento a
través de la práctica es entregarle a
los niños la inquietud y la capacidad de
que ellos tengan curiosidad de poder
aprender sobre el espacio y sobre
nuestro contexto actual contexto actual
pero no solamente acá en la tierra o en
chile sino que en el universo que es lo
que está pasando afuera cómo se forman
las estrellas que hay en una galaxia qué
tipo de galaxias hay aquí es una una
imagen de un taller de pintura que le
dice a unos niños
fue muy entretenido porque es muy
interesante poder aprender a través de
la práctica también una de las cosas que
me gusta destacar y qué
la idea también es incentivar a que se
atrevan también a mezclar ya jugársela
con las diferentes disciplinas trabajar
de una manera interdisciplinaria no como
desde yo desde el arte poder mezclar me
con científicos o un músico con
matemáticos para poder entregar este
conocimiento de una manera mucho más
completa es súper entretenido pero a mí
como pueden ver en este vídeo este es un
mural donde aquí no hay vela dura ni
nada de lo que les dije pero si se ve el
proceso de formación como de una
nebulosa
y super como entretenido poder
experimentarlo a través del conocimiento
no solamente como de una manera estética
sino que también impulsará que se genere
más conexiones más convergencia entre
las diferencias entre las diferentes
disciplinas que hay porque yo creo que
es algo de lo que nos falta hoy en día y
que necesitaríamos como
y poder entregar todo este conocimiento
de una manera más amplia es decir no
solamente desde la teoría no solamente
desde desde la imagen sino que en una
mezcla entre todas y poder así
y llegar a diferentes personas porque
cada uno tiene distintos procesos
cognitivos para aprender entonces así
como entre motivarlos también a que se
la jueguen y que investiguen o que anden
por caminos nuevos porque yo me
encontrado con muy pocas personas y de
hecho somos super pocos los que estamos
haciendo esto como mezclar el arte la
ciencia y generar como estas
está como unión entre varias cosas no
somos pocos pero me encontrado con pocos
pintores a lo menos que represente el
universo ya con conocimiento entonces
impulsarlo a que puedan hacerlo ya que
se atrevan porque no es necesario como
caminar sobre un sobre un camino que ya
está hecho de repente hacer nuevos
caminos
gracias
[Aplausos]